a terror threat at the electric daisy
carnival metro police tells our i-team
they arrested a man just hours before
the music festival started a man who
allegedly planned to kill thousands
david charns here to explain why police
say they took the threat so seriously
david yeah john so about 400 000 people
attended edc over those three days and
today the i-team learning this all
started with an instagram post tagging
the ceo of the company running edc the
day the festival opened last friday so
here's what we know in that threat
police say a north las vegas man said he
would bring balloons full of illicit
fentanyl and pop them potentially
killing many people that is according to
investigators fentanyl is a powder in
just a couple of grains can kill one
person that man later telling police he
was upset that the company didn't refund
his 350 ticket from last year
investigators later identifying the man
as this man 29 year old abraham
castrohone threw a license plate in
another photo on his instagram page and
according to police they became more
concerned about castro hone when they
found out he had a history of quote
dealing with poison like substances
police citing a prior criminal history
in that report
now right now castrohon faces charges of
making threats and owning a gun by an
undocumented citizen he's not due in
court though until next year i'm david
charns live local now